.
LAXALT'S LEAD IS AROUND 13,000.
THAT WAS TO BE EXPECTED.
WE'LL HAVE THE NUMBERS LIVE.
IN GEORGIA, THE FIRST DAYS OF
THE RUN-OFF ARE IN FULL SWING
WITH RAPHAEL WARNOCK IN GREAT
FEAR OF HERSCHEL WALKER.
HE STARTS RIGHT UP RAMPING UP
SMEAR TACTICS AGAINST HERSCHEL
CLAIMING THAT HE HAS A
DISTURBING HISTORY.
MR. WARNOCK, SO DO YOU.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THIS IS A CHOICE ABOUT
COMPETENCE AND ABOUT CHARACTER.
WHEN IT COMES TO CHARACTER, WE
ALL KNOW THAT IT DOESN'T GET ANY
BETTER FOR MY OPPONENT.
I'M RUNNING AGAINST SOMEONE THAT
LIES ABOUT EVERY ASPECT OF HIS
LIFE.
HIS OWN STAFF SAYS HE LIES LIKE
HE'S BREATHING.
I'M JUST REPEATING WHAT THEY
SAID.
HIS OWN STAFF.
WE'VE SEEN THAT HERSCHEL WALKER
HAS A DISTURBING HISTORY.
A PATTERN OF VIOLENCE AGAINST
WOMEN, AGAINST HIS OWN FAMILY
AND HE TAKES -- REFUSES TO TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THAT.
>> Sean: LET'S SEE.
IN 2020, YOUR WIFE, MR. WARNOCK,
CLAIMS THAT YOU TRIED AFTER A
DOMESTIC DISPUTE TO USE A WEAPON
KNOWN AS AN AUTOMOBILE TO RUN
HER OVER.
AND IN FACT RAN OVER HER FOOT.
YOU WERE ARRESTED FOR
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE IN A CASE
INVOLVING CHILD ABUSE AT A CAMP
YOU WERE RUNNING IN WHICH FIVE
INSTANCES WERE DISCOVERED TO
VARYING DEGREES.
ON TOP OF THE CHARACTER ISSUE,
YOU'RE THE GUY THAT IS FRIENDS
WITH LUIS FARRAKHAN.
YOU'RE THE ONE THAT IS FRIENDS
WITH FIDEL CASTRO.
WANT TO TALK ABOUT CHARACTER?
LET'S MAKE IT A RACE ABOUT
CHARACTER.
HERSCHEL WALKER IS SEEING MORE
AND MORE MOMENTUM AHEAD OF THIS
DECEMBER 6 RUN-OFF.
THAT MAN, RAPHAEL WARNOCK IS
AFRAID.
HE'S HAULING IN OVER $3 MILLION,
HERSCHEL WALKER DID, ON THE
FIRST DAY OF THE CAMPAIGN.
HERE WITH MORE ON THIS AND OF
COURSE A SITUATION IN NEVADA IS
LINDSEY GRAHAM, SOUTH CAROLINA
SENATOR.
LET'S START IN NEVADA.
YOU'VE BEEN FOLLOWING THESE
NUMBERS CLOSELY.
WE HAVE ANTICIPATED -- WE
THOUGHT THERE WAS 87,000 BALLOTS
IN CLARK COUNTY.
THAT'S HEAVILY DEMOCRATIC.
SO IT TURNS OUT THERE'S ONLY 50.
NOW AFTER TONIGHT'S DROP,
THERE'S ONLY ABOUT 38,000 VOTES
LEFT IN CLARK COUNTY.
AND THEN YOU GOT A LOT OF VOTES
IN COUNTIES THAT FAVOR ADAM
LAXALT WHO HAS A 13,000, 14,000
VOTE LEAD.
WHAT DOES THAT TELL YOU?
>> THERE'S A PATHWAY IN ARIZONA,
KARI LAKE TOLD YOU HOW WE CAN
GET THERE IN ARIZONA.
THERE'S A 20-LANE HIGHWAY IN
NEVADA.
YOU CAN LAND A SPACE STATION ON
THE PATHWAY THAT ADAM LAXALT
HAS.
60% OF WHAT IS LEFT ARE SAME-DAY
BALLOT DROP-OFFS.
THEY'RE OUR PEOPLE.
SHE CAN'T GET THERE FROM HERE.
4,000 VOTES ARE GOING TO COME IN
SOON, WE THINK, FROM RURAL
NEVADA TO MAKE UP FOR WHAT YOU
SAW TODAY.
SHE CAN'T GET THERE FROM --
>> Sean: THIS JUST CAME IN.
ONE COUNTY JUST CAME IN.
PARENTALLY ADAM LAXALT, WHICH
COUNTY WAS IT?
IT WAS A SMALLER RURAL COUNTY.
THAT IS PLUS 1,000 FOR ADAM
LAXALT.
YOU'RE LIKE NOSTERDOMAS.
>> Sean: I DON'T GET PAID NEARLY
ENOUGH.
>> I DON'T GET PAID ANYTHING.
HE'S GOING TO WIN.
HE WILL TELL YOU TOMORROW HOW HE
WINS.
THEY'RE COUNTING VOTES IN
ARIZONA.
I LIKE WHERE WE'RE AT IN
I LOVE WHERE WE'RE AT IN NEVADA.
WHAT ARE WE GOING TO DO IN
GEORGIA?
WE'RE GOING TO VOTE AGAIN.
OKAY?
NOW, WHAT WARNOCK SAID IS THE
SIGN OF A LOSER.
THAT PRESS CONFERENCE TODAY WHEN
HE WENT AFTER HERSCHEL TELLS ME
HE'S LOSING.
HERE'S ONE RULE YOU NEVER FORGET
IN POLITICS.
THE NIGHTMARE FOR AN INCUMBENT
IS A RUN-OFF.
WARNOCK RAISED $100 MILLION.
EVERY MEDIA OUTLET IN THE
COUNTRY TRIED TO DESTROYED
HERSCHEL AND WARNOCK FELL SHORT.
IF YOU DON'T WIN THE FIRST TIME,
YOU WON'T WIN THE SECOND TIME IN
A RUN OFF.
PURDUE AND LEFLER LOST.
WARNOCK WILL LOSE.
YOU CAN'T BUY A SEAT.
THE LACK OF MONEY CAN LOSE A
SEAT.
I WORRY THAT BLAKE DIDN'T HAVE
ENOUGH MONEY AGAINST KELLY.
HERSCHEL GOT OUTSPENT 2-1.
WE'LL DO THIS AGAIN DECEMBER 6.
JOIN TEAM HERSCHEL.COM TONIGHT.
RIGHT NOW BLOW UP THE INTERNET.
LET'S HAVE THE BEST DAY WE'VE
EVER HAD.
I'M ALL IN, I'M MOVING TO
GEORGIA.
I GOING TO DO EVERYTHING I CAN
TO HELP HERSCHEL.
I'M GOING TO KNOCK ON DOORS, I'M
GOING TO CALL PEOPLE THAT I KNOW
IN GEORGIA.
TEAMHERSCHEL.COM.
WARNOCK IS GOING TO LOSE IF WE
GIVE HERSCHEL THE RESOURCES TO
GET HIS MESSAGE OUT.
HERE'S THE MOST IMPORTANT POINT
I'M GOING TO MAKE TONIGHT.
THEY'RE TRYING TO DESTROY
HERSCHEL TO DETER YOUNG MEN AND
WOMEN OF COLOR FROM BEING
REPUBLICANS.
IF THEY DESTROY HERSCHEL, IT
WILL DETER PEOPLE OF COLOR FROM
WANTING TO BE A CONSERVATIVE
REPUBLICAN BECAUSE YOU JUST HAVE
YOUR LIFE RUINED.
WE CANNOT LET THAT HAPPEN.
WE NEED TO HAVE HIS BACK.
IF HERSCHEL WINS, HE'S GOING TO
INSPIRE PEOPLE ALL OVER GEORGIA
OF COLOR TO BECOME REPUBLICANS
AND I SAY ALL OVER THE UNITED
STATES.
HERSCHEL WALKER IS A NIGHTMARE
FOR LIBERALS.
HE'S AN AFRICAN AMERICAN
CONSERVATIVE.
THEY HAVE BELITTLED HIM, THEY
HAVE TREATED HIM LIKE CRAP.
HIS FAMILY, STAND BY HERSCHEL
TONIGHT.
IF YOU CAN GIVE, GIVE.
IF YOU KNOW SOMEBODY THAT CAN
GIVE, ASK THEM TO DO IT.
TEAMHERSCHEL.COM.
THE CONSERVATIVE MOVEMENT FOR
PEOPLE OF COLOR IS ON THE BALLOT
IN GEORGIA.
WE MUST HELP PEOPLE LIKE
HERSCHEL FOR THE BENEFIT OF OUR
COUNTRY AND THE FUTURE OF
CONSERVATI